liautaud monde s'excuse oblige on se
retrouve sur don't make her nascar la
haye saisie avec un action tellement
magnifique vous pouvez vous pendre tout
de suite maintenant oui mon accent est
nul à chier et alors et alors je suis
pas le seul à avoir un accent bien
français non y'a c'est lourd n'a pas
cinq sioux
allez c'est parti en plus aujourd'hui je
suis fatigué nous croyez moi que c'est
pas le moment d'embêter alors pour ceux
qui ne connaîtraient pas je cois la
perche a dit koné g sans déconner mais
ça m'étonne pas en gros nous volant
d'une voiture on a un timing d'ailleurs
on vient de perdre énormément de seconde
parce que je vous raconte le jeu on a
trois gosses derrière au [ __ ] j'ai
oublié qu'il avait des lunettes des
sortes de ray-ban du futur les ray-ban
du futur adopté les et vous serez le
plus moche de la planète donc l'a envoyé
vont nous faire chier ces petits cons
enfants mathieu cris moi j'ai faim
calmez vous les enfants tonnes et tenez
voici du soda fermé tous vos gueules ah
tiens si l'on tient comme elle s'appelle
céline tiens voilà à mon casque yogan
céline you scream et j'ai perdu voilà
alors vas quand tu es folle aux le but
c'est de rentrer à la maison
on peut voir dans le livre pas bizarre
que mes fils dans c'est pas mes fils qui
veut les adopter un esprit stable en
moins chez très cubique citait minecraft
c'est cool très bien ok you're with the
ditch aulas la colline et roulé roulé
battu à penser son frère mathieu
qu'est ce que c'est que ça 1 tu ne
penses pas ton frère
je sais qu'il ya des gros boutons tu ne
les percent pas dans la voiture
ces deux chiens céline argue over the
album the moonshiners hanachi céline tu
te calmes et ta casquette laquelle
casquette comme ça mon gars 1 1 et qui
n'a pas mais vous n'avez pas de padoue
neeposh les efforts à on se calme ok tu
es belle enfant on s'est vus on vient
juste de se prendre une montagne verte
ça suffit que les enfants elle est
aujourd'hui on ouvre les fenêtres de la
voiture pour se rendre dans la gueule et
on lance la radio
ok on y retourne 1
alors je vous surveille depuis le
rétroviseur faites attention à vous voir
si on peut voir l'autre pinces et sa
soeur est ce qu'il apporte vraiment et
bien non tu l'a passé je t'ai vu dans le
rétroviseur un os les enfants au fini le
trajet sur l'herbe
non mais c'est cameroun monsieur sondés
connaissent qu'un jour je pourrais
réussir à rentrer à la maison blanche et
des clippers points de pau et mon petit
frère est par contre en rentrant mathieu
tu retires ta casquette verte
ça suffit mathieu tu penses pas à chaque
fois tous les jours tu passes au même
moment au même endroit sur la route j'en
ai marre de toi mathieu selim à et
humour les bras tout le papillon ça se
fait pas sur la tête oui je sais c'est
bon je sais que c'est pas un noeud
papillon ça va c'est un chouchou est
alors non on s'est retourné et j'ai
appuyé sur la touche recommencé à me
pourquoi à chaque jeu j'appuie sur une
mauvaise touche qui quitte le joug qui
redémarre tout comme mathieu arrêt de
passer un tas fois que j'ai plus on est
quoi que la voiture mais pas laird a
enfin l'air dès que je touche l'air peu
la voiture se classe
il faut que j'appelle la fasch qu'elle
ment chelem et que moi je sois
tranquille
ok c'était le délire schizophrénique le
plus long du monde tape à gand les
enfants cette fois j'en ai battus et
dans cinq secondes on va voir un
accident il ce sera parce que tu auras
pense et assuré que je me suis retournée
pourtant gueuler c1 depuis que prévu
mathieu yamba de son [ __ ] j'aurais
bien mais qui dès son genre quand même
quand il a peint sa phrase ça fait ça
fera soit la pince à face à nice et 16
mai wall est une jument bas des steaks
les enfants ont fait la guerre à
l'arrière moi je veux rentrer à la
maison
1 même si vous êtes tous les trois
manches pour palestine je pose mon coule
sur ma chaise d'ordinateurs et jean
regrettant un grand pas
mathieu arrête de passer ton frère tu as
her ton frère sa soeur
l'homme qui a d'espacé pourquoi tout
pourquoi tout ne pouvait pas se passer
juste comme ça
la famille parfaite en voiture
non regardez au lieu de ça donne de
penser son frère et voilà céline là et
attention messieurs dames c'est parti
pour la 4è vomi partie de ce jour aller
aux joies des bouts c'est la 1er partie
pour vomir dans le plus grand des calmes
à je sens que mathieu va taper sa soeur
je suis devant un gars hockey qui vont
avoir faim en guerre et bien pas de
problème je vais leur donner des games
ça fait un gars games le film là avec la
meuf qui est dans un jeu j'ai travaillé
mon accent anglais depuis 20 minutes et
est ce jeu se dit dow jones karl vernay
sa casquette de la même couleur que des
montagnes quoi ah ok ils veulent aller
aux salles it what dans les films qu en
penser à une scène où il conduisait mme
bien faire ça avec le volant alors même
si la route est droite il faut tout le
temps ça faire genre qu'il ya tout le
monde s'en fout d'accord ok je m'en vais
en asie mais c'est ça la [ __ ] décret
l'avion
je suis un pro quand un gamer dans son
casque leur atterri toujours sur la ans
de son siège à aller parfois accrochez
vous ça va juste qu'elle abrite
il faut pas faux pas lui dire de ce
terre peut mettre une bonne claque le
foot au bord des routes avec sa cascade
certes il serait bien accueillie par les
montagnes vous en faites pas votre
problème
on dirait pas trop de l'espèce de
voiture de golf les enfants je vais pas
vous faire la route de vote ne vous
inquiétez pas je vais juste vous
chercher en voiture de golf
et pourquoi ce par an meurent quoi il
fait une crise de nerfs au lieu de 2,2
mètres les trois enfants bord de la
route
il décède à ces ça donne des scènes
comme ça quand même super dangereux
wal islah et b d'horreur
ok on leur a donné à tous une boisson et
un paquet de chips on devrait être ok
bon touche pas aux la paix aux gens
temps déjà le silence
oh je suis bien casquette vraiment verte
à je n'ai plus de chine je vous ai déjà
tout au nez comment pouvez-vous encore
avoir faim à celle avancée la morgue et
nous assassiner les gens
alors toi mon gars tiens elle a annoncé
par ailleurs mondiaux
non mais pourquoi